siamo tornati almeno per questo video
siamo tornati perché oggi è un giorno
speciale e un giorno bellissimo siamo
felicissimi e ovviamente l'avrete già
capito dal titolo stiamo andando ad
adottare il nostro primo guzzo siamo
troppo felici e vitale qua e di farmi
vedere allora praticamente questo sarà
un videoblog fino dall'inizio che quando
andremo a prendere che quando porteremo
a casa e vedrete il tutto allora in
questo momento siamo in macchina siamo
stati a negozi di animali abbiamo preso
il trasportino grande se l'abbiamo già
fa in macchina e ora dobbiamo andare in
un altro negozio di animali che un po
più fornito è prendere il resto delle
cose o ci si può organizzare dopo che
l'abbiamo prendo dobbiamo tornare negozi
di animali per misurare la pettorina
perché ci hanno consigliato di portare
direttamente il pozzo da fallo a
misurare per essere sicuri che gli sta a
noi siamo troppo felici veramente siamo
già stati a vederlo al canile e ci siamo
innamorati e non ci stiamo andando a
prenderlo è sopresi si è ancora non ci
posso credere il lotto più puzza nonne
che amiamo gli animali così tanto mi
viene da piangere allora vi porteremo
con noi in questa giornata in cui
lotteremo il nostro cucciolo è vi dico
già che non ha ancora un nome non
abbiamo deciso ancora un nome
quindi quando lo vedrete è prima non di
non scrivete adesso consigli dei nomi
perché prima dovete vederlo è vedere che
nome gli potrebbe stare in mente che no
ve li do solo dopo perché gli do minho
guardate mi raccomando il blog fino alla
pipì farò fare domande e poi eroga qui
per rispondermi anche se avete già un
cane se avete piaciuto un cucciolo
ho anche bisogno dei vostri consigli si
siamo comunque informati tantissimo
perché volevamo essere preparati abbiamo
letto guardato video il sacco di cose
niente siamo felicissimi ora andiamo a
comprare qualcos'altro per il cucciolo
negozio o che abbiamo preso un po di
cose le piazze di animali abbia compreso
le ciotole dei giochini le bustine per
raccogliere la cassetta
e delle cose per pulire altre cose
comunque dopo vi facciamo vedere tutto
ora stiamo votando al canile finalmente
a prenderlo subito
emozionati per contenti e non vediamo
l'ora di presentarvelo è un maschietto e
a tre mesi è una delle volontarie del
canile soggetto che dovrebbe essere noto
2 gennaio
sappiamo anche quando festeggiare il suo
compleanno il prossimo
tra poco arriviamo e lo vedrete
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi eccolo cuori cuzzolino
abbiamo messo nel trasportino e poverino
ovviamente è un po spaventato non
capisce cosa sta succedendo piccolo mi
sono seduta ma dietro per rassicurarlo
un po e farlo stare tranquillo e
ovviamente sarà tra un po spaventato
perché non sa cosa sta succedendo
per loro dolci sicuro però fa subito
romeni un po totti numero filoso nicolò
non ti preoccupare che avrei un abito
felicissima con noi ora non capisci cosa
sta succedendo ma non ti preoccupare
piccolino tesoro tesoro non ti
preoccupare sai che ti vogliamo già
tanto tanto bene potentino
stai tranquillo è purtroppo questa
strada e un po
è un po come si dice ma un codice stata
piccolino
non ti preoccupare piccolo prima piccolo
non piangiamo poverino non ti
preoccupare tutto il forum andrà tutto
bene ovviamente ora non capisce cosa ci
fai dentro questo trasportino non sa
cosa sta succedendo ma non vediamo l'ora
di coccolarlo tutto portarlo con noi in
giro fargli fare una passeggiatina e
dargli tante coccole tanti bozzini non
ti preoccupare tesoro troppo con
rinviamo caso starei tranquillo
tranquillo piccolino cucciolo o mi si
stringe il cuore sentirlo piangere però
ovviamente non capisse adesso pizzino
non ti preoccupare
tra poco arriviamo a casa dobbiamo
prendere la pettorina e il guinzaglio
etto perché dobbiamo misurarlo
poi lo portiamo a lavarlo a secco
cucciolo stiamo per arrivare non c'è
troppo rumore eccoci qua allora siamo
quasi arrivati quindi l'abbiamo posta
dalla gabbietta perché si spaventava
tantissimo e ha iniziato a piangere un
sacco sono un sacco di paura e quindi
l'abbiamo tolto il loro assicurato
coccolato e ora è tranquillissimo
scusate lo strato è un po visto stato
eccolo qua un amore l'abbiamo portato al
negozio di animali a fargli fare un
uno shampoo secco perché ancora cucciolo
quindi ancora lo shampoo completo no
però gli abbiamo fatto fare uno show
proseguirò profumo tantissimo core dote
che umore
[Musica]
ora lo sto imparando a casa noi siamo
nella casa nuovo avevo detto che ci
siamo trasferiti e quindi ora vedrete un
pò di spoiler ma ancora non è sistemata
del tutto abbiamo ancora un sacco di
cose da fare però abbiamo anche ore
abbiamo quasi finito quindi tra un po di
provvedere meglio eccolo qua tesoro di
solo un pelo siamo arrivati e ora
viviamo la palma e poi facciamo fare un
giretto per fare i bisognini anche
vediamo come reagisce ora che scende
eccoci a casa lui è un pochino spazzato
però è sempre affettuoso come scadenza
rivedere cosenza il tumore o ti stai
specchiando pensi che sia un altro cane
league
ciao a tutti futurismo è tornato vivace
che c'è anche vitale che innamorato già
perdutamente
io me lo fa tutti svizzero al truccare
piccolo ora ti diamo la palpa finiamo la
pappa detto osservando un po vedendo
come la sua nuova casetta figlio fatti
vedere fatti vedere dove sono mai
problemi persa da cani
molto meglio
riprendiamo la prima cioè non la sua
prima papa già battuto però la prima
volta temi la diamo noi è preso proprio
da vediamo
[Musica]
clicca che giochino in pratica in questo
giochino si mettono i biscottini dentro
e lui deve cercare sorprendere qualcuno
già fatto cadere ma non se ne verremo
accordo piccoli del riflesso
[Musica]
se ce n'è in corso ancora uno qua dentro
e così in cameretta
noi li abbiamo preparato il trasportino
aperto con delle traversine e dei
giochini non parlate un sisma cosa
preferisce preferisce fare per te ma
dimmi tu e se ma insomma quasi letino
più morbido per che volete e niente
stanotte non penso che dormire molto
perché lepri venuti con un cucciolo sono
un po difficili ma vi aggiorno domani
mattina vi faccio sapere come è andata
buongiorno allora eccola lì
eccolo lì che dorme finalmente e mattino
già un po tardi vi racconto come andata
salute allora abbiamo dormito pochissimo
perché si svegliava ogni più ma non ora
40 minuti e piangeva un sacco perché
voleva insomma attenzioni voleva essere
accarezzato quindi ogni ora più o meno
ci svegliavamo lo carezza momo lo
tranquillizzava mo e lui dopo un po si
riaddormenta va quindi tornavamo a
dormire però poi dopo 40 minuti un'ora
si risvegliava piangeva nuovamente e noi
lo ri accarezzavamo tutto non so se
stiamo sbagliando a dargli attenzione
dal bie troppo attenzioni magari
dobbiamo lasciarlo piangere insomma per
di capire che la notte deve dormire non
lo so consigliatemi poi nei commenti
perché se voi avete già esperienza con
dei cuccioli magari staffette meglio
come fare insomma non riuscivamo a
dormire con lui che piangeva e non
volevamo farlo piangere quindi per
quello l'abbiamo sempre accarezzato e
quindi siamo stanchi di sonno e lui
ovviamente stanco lo stesso e sta
dormendo
la mattina e ci sono stati un paio di
incidenti in casa ha fatto la pupù era
pp
lo abbiamo portato fuori ma non abbiamo
fatto in tempo e poi questo mattina lo
abbiamo portato fuori vita l'elaborato
fuori ma non ho fatto niente
però quando è tornato in casa l'ha fatta
quindi dobbiamo ancora trainarlo bene a
fare i suoi bisognini fuori e niente
sapevamo già che i primi giorni sono
comunque più complicati con un cucciolo
bissone
ho fatto un ebook in una peste china
cookie si è insediato
questo dunque non è questo coniugi noi
sia un pilone una passeggiatina la
passeggiatina che abbiamo siamo ci
scappi il mio borsellino
così tutto il 56 lo abbiamo portato
supportate è affatto la tecnica pippi
quindi speriamo sia quando vediamo che
c'è paziente fatti vedere
[Musica]
facciamo una donna e pechino
buzzone di un pittore che oggi si
innamorano di evitare ogni cosa e lo
fate gli si illuminano gli occhi e di
far subito incontro anche a me viene
incontro per completare
non lo so sembra più agitato lo è ecco
passatore calore verso volevamo
raccontarvi un po la sua storia perché
ci siamo resi conto che non vi abbiamo
raccontato un po la storia purtroppo la
sua storia è molto triste
piccolino allora lui era in canili
assieme a 6 due fratellini in canile mi
hanno dato il nome tequila al via i due
fratelli bacardi e gene bellissimi
bacardi bianco e nero aver assunto lo ha
fatto velocissimo invece jim era tre
colori nero beige qua e bianco al centro
con un piacere ste 1 marrone allora per
fortuna sono stati
tutti e tre adottati ma hanno avuto una
storia molto triste perché sono dei
cuccioli che sono stati abbandonati
ancora purtroppo c'è questo problema che
le persone abbandonano i cani
io non riesco a concepire come si possa
arrivare ad abbandonare degli animali a
lasciarli per strada a una morte quasi
certa perché la maggior parte muoiono
investiti o muoiono di stenti per
fortuna allora loro sono stati
abbandonati per strada dentro una
scatola per fortuna sono stati trovati
da delle volontarie e sono stati portati
al canile non fossero stati trovati
sarebbero morti investiti morti di fame
noi guardiamo le commemorain che queste
creaturine come si fa a lasciare chiusi
in una struttura per strada
l'importante comunque è che ci sono
persone buone che salvano i cani i gatti
gli animali di recupero dalla strada ci
sono i canili che li tengono volontari
che li recuperano esistono persone che
li adottano fortunatamente infatti se ne
avete la possibilità non comprate
cercate di adottare perché i canili sono
sempre pieni ci sono tantissimi cani che
sognano una famiglia sognano di vivere
una famiglia e ricevere tanto fumetto
tante compone e sognano di non dover
passare tutta la loro vita e morire
dentro una stanza di cemento
praticamente cercate di donare una vita
migliore a queste creaturine se ne avete
la possibilità di poter adottare un cane
un gatto guardate i canili
sono veramente tanti incarichi tante
tante età che ci sono già tanti anni che
magari stanno giorni anche libia non
hanno praticamente un futuro che si sono
rassegnati a vivere così invece possono
dare un santo di amor soprattutto un
cane in canile saprà che lo avete
salvato infiammerà davvero davvero tanto
ovviamente dovete essere sicuri di voler
e poter adottare adottare un cane non è
gioco non è un giocattolo è un impegno è
un impegno per 10 15 anni
bisogna ta di tante attenzioni di e da
lì tanto amore bisogna esserlo ci sono
anche delle spese veterinarie cibo
quindi è un impegno ma impegno che paga
[Musica]
veramente per tutti
carofiglio chiuderlo tenuti nei due
video di adesso
noi pensiamo che gli animali siano
comunque gli animali sono creature
meravigliose donarsi da per tanto amore
e noi siamo salvarli spero che
considererete che adotta un cane al
canile e quando ne avrete la possibilità
o state cercando
fatemi sapere le vostre storie ne come
se avete adottato un cane al canile
oppure un gatto trovatello
scriveteci nei commenti fateci sapere
come si chiama
come l'avete trovato ma che si salva in
tutto siamo curiosi marito adesso
trovare un nome per questo piccolo dolci
netto sono stati sicuri non sono
giocatori de sio no ma ne avevamo
pensato zappalà chiederà qualche
nomignolo e voi scrivete suggerite un
nome in parte al comune sia
caratterialmente che ti aspetta un nome
che li starebbe bene e non vi viene in
mente niente vi di sau i nomi abbiamo
pensato no io che ci ha suggerito e voi
potete votare questi nomi quindi nei
commenti invece di scream e quindi tutte
le 9 allora io volevo chiamarlo lino
lino perché semolino come lingua perché
il problema di anita già suggerito
semola perché il colore della sail ferma
latino e della spada nella roccia dalla
pagina mario di sanremo la semolino il
lino sense e molino lì non mi piace
tanto e poi ci hanno suggerito anche
merlino 20 fare bere ma anche bollino
berlino lina carrellino
cacciato suggerito allora arthur alto
ambleto prima mente a me perché secondo
me lui o principino amleto era il
principe di danimarca la croce di abiti
che è la mia presenta tra l'altro però
noi un posteriore quindi non la canzone
che da ieri sera per marchetti ormoni e
poi ecco io volevo chiamarlo drago come
draco malfoy perché è biondo con gli
occhi se le mappe rojas radicale non
piace qui vedendo caratterialmente
troppo d'oro per essere un dramma
quindi cosa ne pensate in questi nomi
merlino devo dire che mi piace o se
avete altri sul territorio e foto
scrivete seri nei commenti noi andranno
federico sisti inserimenti e poi andremo
a sceglierlo se scegliamo uno dei nomi
che sono lettere suggerito ovviamente il
vizio adotteremo e guardate tutti con me
smettetela i nomi che vi piacciono di
più così vediamo quali sono esaltati pd
quelli che mi piacciono di più anche
colonia dove è già super viziato tutti
gli facciamo un sacco di noi le
chiamiamo tutte le carrozzine lo
facciamo giocare tanto che i giochi non
montiamo fuori a spasso alle ore super
contento questo cadere chiedendo ma
ammetteva come mai lo sfondo e verde
allora c'è una strana coincidenza perché
qua non abbiamo scelto noi mobili
ovviamente perché non è nostra la casa e
immobili sono 20 e cedere gestire il mio
colore preferito più
non vi preoccupate che li faremo bene
liste presso la bellissima
abbiamo davanti un pochino né corteo poi
faremo vedere che tutto si potesse
sapere che altri in video vorrebbe
vedere con questo gioco dopo un altro
nome di milano dopo il nome troppo serio
per questo dolce quindi il privato
esistente nei commenti da state un bel
laiche mese vediamo alla prossima sul
prossimo video ciao
[Musica]